all right now we take a breath um it
seems like uh the question really takes
a left turn right
because all of this stuff as i mentioned
before this is all part a part b
we're definitely we're deeply in complex
numbers territory
and then somehow in part c and d for
that matter um
all the complex numbers are gone we're
in we're in real number land again
so somehow we're gonna have to do some
operations here um
especially being that it says hence so
i'm gonna have to step off from whatever
this result was part b
i'm to have to go from here and all of
the you know imaginary stuff that is
sort of implied
in part b i'm going to have to do some
operations that will make it come out in
the wash so that once i get to part c
i just have the real components left so
how do i go about that
well i'm going to say this line here is
going to be my starting point
but in order to you know write this in a
form that actually gets me to
here i'm going to think about well what
what is omega equal to
it's i'm just going to write this back
down here um it's it's this
right so i'm going to grab this this is
my part c proof
i'm going to say since i can write
omega like this i can also write it in
uh exponential form and you might think
well why did uh why did he go and
immediately think of exponential form
like where is that in the question and
the answer is
i'm dealing with all these powers you
see i've got all these indices here and
even though i can use derivative theorem
to deal with powers when i'm reading in
polar form
as you saw up here right number one it's
much more concise number two it's a lot
easier to deal with this
if i write things in exponential form so
i'm going to say
omega can be written as e to the i
two pi on nine that's that's just a
straight writing of this you can see
um the modulus is one um and my argument
is two pi over nine so this is my r e to
the i
theta so if this is true if this is my
new way of writing omega then i can
simply substitute that into
this line up here right like because i
just proved that in part b
so i'm going to go ahead and do that
even though this is
i'm just checking the way they wrote it
um they actually wrote it in in a more
helpful order you can see
they've started with the omega with the
lowest power and then going to the
highest power
i'm going to take the result the way
they wrote it even though mine is the
same just backwards okay and you'll see
why
in a second so i'm going to substitute
this
way of writing this form of omega into
my result
from part b so i'm going to say from
or maybe i should say just i should say
that substituting into
substituting omega
into b
that gives me this so i'm going to i'm
going to start with these low powers and
then i'm going to build up to the high
powers okay
i'm just going to write it as as as
stated so i'm going to go
um e to the i 2 pi on 9.
that's the first one that's just omega
and then the next one i want to write is
omega
squared well you can see that when you
raise something to the power of 2
that has the effect of multiplying that
in this index by 2
so i'm going to get e to the i
4 pi on 9. that's omega squared
here comes omega cubed i feel like i'm
going to run a space on this line it's
going to be multiplying that index by
3. so that's omega
cubed there and i'm just going to i am
definitely going to run out of space so
i'm just going to drag this
all over a teeny bit like so that'll fit
okay so what am i up to i just needed to
make a cube let's do omega to the power
of 4
so that's i to the 8 pi on
9 and i'm as you can see i'm just going
up in
integer multiples of 2 pi on nine so uh
my next one will be
ten pi on nine i guess ten pi on nine
i need uh twelve pi on
nine i'm almost there
i need to get up to 16 pi on nine
because that would be omega to the power
of
eight so here comes the last one 16 pi
on
nine so there's everything on my left
hand side and now i'm going to have the
right hand side which
as we saw in part b was negative one
okay so this looks like a bit of a mess
but i want to
think about what's going on here and how
i can you know most logically work out
what's the next step that will help me
the most okay
so a few things that i notice for
starters and i'm just going to highlight
them here
i've got a couple of values in here
namely this one and also this one is
going to come in
and these are actually nice values of
theta
right the arguments are in this case 6
pi on 9 and in this case
12 pi on 9 you could write this as 2 pi
on
3 and i guess you would write this as 4
pi on 3. now these are
multiples of pi on 3 multiples of pi on
6. they
are i can get exact values out of those
right so so that's nice i'm going to
take advantage of that
shortly um because uh as you can see
when you have a look up
in uh part c thing you can see there's
no there's no six pounds pi on nine um
it's been actually
evaluated out so that's why it doesn't
appear so that's the first thing i
notice
and then the second thing is as we
pointed out earlier just by comparing
part b and part c
you've got complex stuff up here and
then you've only got real stuff here so
somehow all of our imaginary components
are going to have to
vanish away they're going to have to
cancel in some form so how am i going to
do that
well what i want to notice is that just
like i saw before you can see i wrote
this in in polar form to remind us right
we've already used the periodicity of
cos and sine we've already used it a
couple of times in this question
to evaluate that you know this is always
going to equal 1 this is always going to
equal 0.
but we can use it again this period of
city right even though i've written it
in exponential form
each of these stands for cos for example
cos 10 pi 9 plus i sine 10 pi on 9. so
this is still periodic every 2 pi
radians
now the reason why that is useful is if
i just take for example this guy here
that's very messy let's try that again
i can add or subtract any multiple
of 2 pi and it's going to give me an
equivalent complex number right
so if for example if i subtracted 2 pi
from this
that would be the same because i noticed
that this is you know denominator of 9
that would be the same as subtracting 18
pi
on 9. that would be the equivalent right
so
what what happens to my uh to my index
up here
well you're going to get just watch for
it carefully e to the i
i'm subtracting uh 18 pound 9 from
10 pi on 9. so you're going to go
negative it's going to be
negative eight pi on
nine now i like this for two reasons
number one
it's a principal argument right ten pi
on nine you can see you went from the
positive side of the real axis and you
spun around past pi radiance so
um that's that's just an unnecessarily
large angle that's that's the first
thing i noticed
but the second thing is you see how this
angle is exactly opposite
to this angle here right so what this
means is
these two numbers and i'm going to write
it now you can see i've got it from just
up here
obviously those here i've gone to the
wrong tool this
immediately previous complex number here
these two guys are
are actually conjugates they are related
in this very important way i could write
this as e to the i 8 pi
9 and e to the i uh a pi or 9 with a bar
over the top in fact that's exactly what
i'm going to do on the next
line and the reason why having
conjugates together is so nice is
because
we introduced the idea of conjugates
because of how much they cancel with
each other right the real parts are the
same
the imaginary parts are opposite in sine
and that's what's going to enable me to
cancel everything out and i'll just have
the real components
i'm getting a little bit ahead of myself
though because i've just noticed this
connection between these two but i have
all the rest of them
to also write so what i'm going to do is
i'll leave these guys
i'll duplicate these and get rid of this
extra stuff i don't need
so all of these are going to remain
unchanged but when i do this same
operation
to all of my other complex numbers here
right when i subtract
18 pi over 9 because that gives me the
same complex number you will notice
there's a pairing thing that happens
again
so when you do this 12 pi on 9 minus 18
pi on 9
that's going to give me e to the i minus
6 pi on 9. so you can see that
um this kind of uh it sort of goes out
from the middle these are pairing up
this is the negative 6 by 9 this is the
positive 6.9
what's my next one along you can just
follow the pattern from here right
they are still 2 pi or 9 spaced out
because these are
of course the 9th roots of unity and
that's what we know about them on the
unit circle
so this will be negative 4 pi on
9 and then my last one will be e to the
i negative 2 pi on 9 and that's equal to
negative 1.
oh accidentally change color there so
let's write that properly
so what have i got here just so you're
you're
following along i'm going to get this
and
this paired up i'm going to pair up this
guy
and this guy everything will pair up one
term
with its conjugates so we should write
that that that step of logic i've said
it allowed but i haven't got it on my
working here
so you can see all of these terms out
the front
are going to stay the same
and then in fact when i have a look down
the line all of these
will be equivalent to to these original
four
but they'll be the conjugates so again
sorry i'm going to be a teeny bit lazy
here and i'm going to write these with
the bars
over the top they're equal to
negative one i should know that my my
order has gone a bit funny because i've
been lazy but this guy over here
this is the conjugate for this term so i
should um write that
like so that's the conjugate there um
this
this one here is the conjugate here and
it keeps going along this term is the
conjugate
this term is the conjugate that's how
i've done my pairing
okay now just to remind you because i
sort of did it verbally but i want this
to be
clear in the working this is after all a
hence
show that question so let's just remind
ourselves what happens when you add two
conjugate numbers together or two
conjugates of a complex number
if uh if z were say equal to
a plus i b then i would have its
conjugate z bar
equal to a minus i b that's just our
definition
of a conjugate so when you take
therefore
z plus z bar what you're getting is the
complex number
plus the same thing but the only change
is that you've got um the imaginary
component the opposite sign
right so clearly these these two terms
here will cancel with each other and
that just leaves you to
a instead of writing a i'm going to
write that in a form that's more helpful
to me in the question which is
the real form of my complex number z